do you hear that
wedding bell oh is that what that is
today an exciting day for brides and
grooms who are getting ready to walk
down the aisle
it is the return of the bridal
spectacular wedding expo and it's at the
world market center candace charles
joins us live from the south hall with
your sneak peek at the deals and
must-haves this year so you've taken off
your bridal gown what's going on candace
yeah yeah i've changed out of the bridal
gown i'm back to my irregular
not as beautiful but sort of beautiful
dress because i want to show you some
other dresses ladies you know i got you
covered couples you know i got you
covered there's so much to see at the 60
second bridal spectacular wedding expo a
lot of vendors are going to be here and
i got a first time vendor here with me
she has a very special story that i'm
very excited to tell i'm joined by liz
goff of izzy designs tell us a little
bit about the dresses you have here this
one has been column name it's beautiful
at beth right so annabeth is actually my
edc gown love it you know we we love to
party in vegas absolutely so what i do
is i actually design custom wedding
gowns for any bride
this particular one was actually
requested by an edc bride so i made sure
to add her to my collection but the one
thing that i do that's different than
every designer that's out there who
they're amazing by the way
is i actually design gowns that are
adaptive so what that means is i have
wheelchair options i have options for
ports i have options for
any shape any size any reason you want
to get married i've been a bride four
times right on to the same guy and we
get it girl
i love it so i just love weddings and
we've been married for 23 years and i've
been designing clothes and things for
family i'm a special needs mom and so
each one of my gowns is designed
specifically for that bride and we
customize it we go through the whole
process of look at that train right
and she's actually that all the brides
that have mobility issues i designed
them so they could specifically
be the bride not
their disability so
beautiful okay you got to tell me what
are we looking at for prices and where
can people find you if they can't make
it up here
so you can find me on my website is is
the original designs that's izi original
designer sorry
is the originals
dot com
new new website sorry guys um and i'm
located kind of in the summerlin south i
actually do this out of my home right
now
so
price point wise i try to work with my
brides i do eco-friendly gowns so i can
actually take an old wedding gown
upcycle it to a brand new gown that
looks nothing like it or create
something from scratch and so you're
looking at that roughly thousand dollar
is your entry price point
the sky's the limit the more bling
the more change right exactly
i love it thank you so much liz for
coming down here bright and early and
chatting with us we love it definitely a
booth to come by and you guys come by
starting tonight at six there's another
day for you tomorrow as well we're
talking as well about the court trends
coming up what are the trends you know i
got you covered with all the details and
of course tickets are 18
28 for vip you can find more details on
eight news now dot com for now live from
the world market center i'm candice
charles 8 news now that is incredible a
local designer inclusivity just love it
all candace thank you